J'adore qu'est-ce que vous maudissez cela ressemble
à du tonnerre
vous avez une belle vie Kurtis nous dit le
meilleur compliment que vous pouvez lui donner
un coup d'œil à sa forme de vie
hé les gars font quelque chose de bien ce
n'est pas toujours si facile
non ça m'a dit comment  étrange
Kurtis a agi ces derniers temps
quelqu'un a volé ça parle-moi de ces
rêves d'
accord chéri si tu ne te sens pas bien nous l'
avons compris n'arrête pas es-tu
fou tu as manqué à l'église ce
matin Curtis pense à
nettoyer cette tempête  s'abriter à l'arrière
tu sais que les dépenses que nous avons à venir tu
veux gaspiller de l'argent sur un stupide
abri de tornade